anyway I'm going to do uh I got I got
requests so I'm going to play a couple
songs
wow little something how come you left
out the 400y old uh
symbol did you write this
yeah yeah what is that what is that
called what was what
mamb MOS which
means it's just a a style of Rhythm oh
is that is that real MOS yeah that was a
mosm not to be confused
with uh Cha Cha
Cha that's amazing I you know that makes
me jealous to be honest with you I can't
you see you see entertainers all day no
but I my real I and I think see you're
living the dream that I would love to
live I think most and you probably have
heard this before but most comedians
want to be a rock star and most rock
stars want to be comedians yeah and I
don't mean it's not necessarily Rock but
you want to be able to do music or you
do it all is this the perfect setup I
would imagine no it's it's way it's more
well there's a coffee table in the
middle of a set there seems to be a
coffee table uh it's cuz his water's in
the way oh if you didn't have your water
we would be able to bring and I could
read while I do it too yes there's a
lot no one does this no one reads and if
you're just listening to this he's got a
book open
on oh no oh the book closed in the
middle of the
song no one does this no one you're not
doing it right
now
can you read out
loud I had a light bulb
moment well it has to be with a song I
said what a song song from the crosses a
ridiculously cheery song about looking
at the bright side like a Disney song
that was good I'll play a ballad a slow
sort of
like okay well and and well I tell
people to
subscribe comment this is like a more of
a was sad I stepped on my water what'
you step on his water it's that's why
you don't bring it on that's why it
should be on a table you're
right you're no Paul McCartney go ahead
this is in memorium I'm doing an in
memorium drum
thing as we close out
2023 Fred is uh you can see Fred I was
going to
talk
Fred Armon is uh a brilliant comic a
brilliant comic who uh you can go see do
standup you can see him from time to
time playing the drums he is the band
leader and the producer on Seth Meyers
uh the 8B band 8G
[Music]
Band